oh
[Music]
hi i'm asia holloway
hello i'm trey holloway
[Music]
and we are married
we are the halloween
[Music]
so i proposed i did it up in the ferris
wheel will you marry me
trey
i'm gonna need a verbal confirmation
it was magical we got married in
september everything shut down we were
getting married in six weeks we had to
now at this point cancel 96 people we
had already paid almost close to
everything for the previous place that
we were going to get married and then
they were like yeah we can't give you
your money back in full it was just a
chaotic but it was like the most
beautiful chaos ever it was cool
chaos nonetheless
we're treating you to a romantic
honeymoon stay at a hawk's cave resort
in the florida keys along with
snorkeling massages yoga and boat rides
for real
[Music]
say what no
the full florida keys experience
we were just talking about that
you guys listening with me literally
y'all listening literally
i was just crazy
talking about that we're like all right
we gotta go to the keys babe we gotta go
to the keys i'm literally shook
we just got to the room ocean suite
cute
[Laughter]
this is like your heaven oh wow oh my
gosh i love this
[Music]
first activity i know i'm excited
oh
my god you've never been a helicopter
right i haven't
i'm nervous
i feel like a superhero like i'm taking
off let's go you guys got the gulf of
mexico off on the left you got the
atlantic ocean off on the right we do
tend to see shark stingrays manatees
every once in a while dolphins and
turtles
all right here is hawk's cave resort
i'm proud of you very proud of myself
we saw sharks we saw barracuda we saw
dolphin yeah glad we got to see the keys
that way for sure specifically because
that was bird's eye view is nice
hi how are you
thank you
you're nice in a row thank you
sweetheart
[Music]
trey
yes
are you having a good time yes this is
exactly what i needed
that oil smells amazing wow
how do you feel i feel so good it worked
out a lot that was it yeah you were
quick crackling over there
historically both of us are not great at
yoga yoga had a in front of my mind but
it's breezy it's beautiful it's going to
be great just take a breath here inhale
[Music]
really push
down that you're balancing really like
think about it there
nice
okay next up so we're about to get on
that boat i'm diving down to the bottom
are you do your thing
[Music]
[Music]
i love today
it has been amazing
[Music]
we are on our way to our
sunset marina dinner i'm so hungry
so i am about to eat literally
everything
let's
go thank you
wow that's what i'm sorry about
this looks amazing i'm really happy that
we were able to at least celebrate our
relationship and like our marriage
because we really didn't get a chance to
right i think this was just like the
best way to do it absolutely and then
now we finally get a chance to breathe
and chill and like take yeah a proper
honeymoon okay these
fire
bombs yeah foods are great
no the food is really good you know what
i'm loving
the fish is so fresh that looks really
good my love
cheers cheers to us to us we had a
vacation amazing trip that i hope we
get to come on again soon me too
good morning love good morning
sweetheart what's the activity for today
today we are deep sea fishing which we
both have never done this is our boat
for today
and we
are going to do our best to fight these
fish
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
set the trap whoa
i feel you baby i got you nice [ __ ]
[Music]
not easy
not easy
[Music]
let's go stay with
oh my it that was the hardest thing i've
ever done
that is not for the week
that is hard man oh man fishing was
great and i hadn't gone fishing in
forever i've never caught a fish and
trey caught two
massive fish now they say you eat what
you catch we're gonna go cook it up that
looks delicious
it's so good
oh this one
wow
[Music]
hello
how you doing my name is captain captain
mark
hey jacob nice to meet you we're on our
sunset
it's so beautiful it's stunning the sun
is beaming down the breeze is nice and
light
i feel like we haven't been able to
relax in a very long time what was your
favorite excursion probably the
helicopter right
just because i i even though you're so
nervous that's why okay because you know
i need to be thrown into something
so i feel like that was perfect and i
love the water so like to be able to see
it like over
like that i'd never i've never done
anything like that it's so nice to have
like something
in the usa
you know that you can come and like feel
like you're
somewhere else
with like warm clear water
we're all busy again and
work is back up so it's nice to take
like a breather and it's been a
beautiful breather to take with like
excursions that we probably would have
never never done probably not so that's
like i think we are this is it's
gorgeous it was like a perfect perfect
trip
[Music]
you